[Music]
[Music]
I'm also pleased to welcome dr. Elias
azor hooni director of the National
Institutes of Health who will now give
the graduation address dr. Zerhouni
thank you very much it's really a
privilege for me to be here and
celebrate with you on this beautiful day
I also wish my mother-in-law was here to
see what I was doing today because I
still have to convince her on a daily
basis that her daughter made the right
choice many years ago I'm honored to be
here because I also as a parent myself
can feel the joy of your parents and
friends who were here as a parent I
remember the birth of my first son as if
it was yesterday and I can tell you your
parents also remember those 22 years ago
and days where you were born for you
those 22 years may have seemed very long
and arduous but I can tell you for
parents they are very short they all
remember you as a baby and they can't
believe have you become such a
formidable graduate at one of the most
prestigious institution in the world and
that's an illustration of what I call
the relativity principle of time and
aging the older you are the faster start
the faster time seems to go by and the
faster tuition bills seem to come
through as well but you know you are the
legacy of your parents to this world and
they all deserve our heartfelt
recognition for doing such a good job
and I'd like all the graduates if you
don't mind to give a round of applause
to your parents
it's also a great honor for me to give
this address in the last year of
president Charles vest extraordinary
tenure at MIT there's no question that
dr. vest from my point of view as a
federal agency official today is one of
the most influential thought leaders in
higher education he has this rare
combination that you don't find a lot in
life that combines vision and flawless
execution well last night he conducted
the Boston Pops with a flawless
execution I hear president vest were
impressed
recently my younger son Adam actually
was initiated in a fraternity called Phi
Kappa Tsai and I was checking to make
sure that this was a good fraternity a
decent one I found out that dr. vest was
a member of that fraternity so when
people ask me now but my son Adam SEL
don't worry he belongs to the exact same
fraternity dr. vest belongs to so I'm
very proud to to do this in his last
year but when I was preparing my speech
what can you say to a 2,200 very bright
graduates that will make a difference in
in telling them about where you see life
and where you see a field of science
where you see yourself and as I was
preparing my speech was looking at what
was the best strategy to do that and I
came across the story of a commencement
speaker at Yale University who had the
great idea of using every letter of the
Galle name as a starting concept so he
used Y for youth and he went on and on
about youth and then he used a for
ability which you all have and he went
on and on and from the back of the room
somebody said thank God were not the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology so
I give up on that strategy I'm not going
to use that strategy today
instead I'll tell you about what I think
are the very critical both scientific
challenges of the 21st century but also
what is your role in it the challenge
frankly for us in the 21st century is
one that we have brought upon ourselves
and I'll just go back in history a
little bit to give you the perspective
of how I see it when you when you think
about the universe who you hear that
about 13.7 billion years ago there was a
big bang and all of that Big Bang came
the universe and then planets and solar
systems and galaxies organized
themselves that was the first Big Bang
but there were other big bangs the earth
came about five billion years ago and
about four billion years ago with a
mysterious event life appeared and what
happened is that through replication of
very special molecules DNA and RNA
something very unique happen where by
natural evolution allowed through
multiple variations and survival of the
fittest the emergence of a very diverse
life on Earth but there is a third Big
Bang and this is the one you live again
today which you have to take account of
and that is the Big Bang of knowledge it
occurred about a hundred thousand years
ago when about ten thousand individuals
at most as we look at the genome and we
look at the variation of the genome
across the human population it is very
clear that all of us have come from the
same founding population of 10,000
individuals in Africa about a hundred
thousand years ago so we're not that
different from each other in historical
terms and yet that changed the game of
life because through knowledge through
our ability to our intelligence were
able to transfer information from one
child from one parent to a child from a
parent to another one and through
generations were able to develop tools
of adaptation the world has never seen
we've been able to change our
environment at a speed at a velocity
that is much faster than what we can
adapt
to ourselves through our natural
mechanisms of natural evolution let me
give you an example obesity is a
emerging public health threat this year
the Center for Disease Control said that
obesity will be the second is the second
cause of premature mortality and
morbidity in this country now why is
that because for millions of years our
genes evolved in the context of food
scarcity there was not a lot of food
around us for millions of years and all
of a sudden because of our intelligence
because of our knowledge we changed that
in less than 50 years most of our genes
are in fact designed to allow you to
accumulate energy and keep that energy
which then translates itself into
overweight and obesity well what are we
gonna do about it what I will dare to
say to you is that life sciences and
their applications will be the defining
challenge of the 21st century bar none
and the reason is that we are changing
our environment at the speed which will
require us to understand life sciences
to a degree we do not understand today
and let me tell you it will require the
intelligence and commitment of many
classes of graduates like yours it is
not coming from biology is it will not
the solution will not come from biology
alone it will come from the integration
of biology and computer sciences and
mathematics and physics and chemistry
and we want to encourage that to happen
why is this a great opportunity for you
let me tell you a little story about a
few weeks ago I was at a meeting of the
annual convention of all the
biotechnology executives all the CEOs of
the many biotechnology companies in this
country were there assembled in New York
with their investment bankers now you
know this must be a very important
meeting for someone who is trying to get
funds for their idea and I just
conducted a poll and I said to them
I am the director of the NIH I'm
supposed to is the national nation's
medical research agency I want to ask
you a question how much do you think you
know of what you need to know to be
effective in combating obesity or
diabetes and any of the healthcare
challenges that we have in front of us
as the question do you think you know
90% of what you need to know and no one
answered that fifty percent no one
raised their hand 20 percent no one
raised their hand so I said what what
about less than 10 percent everybody
raised their hand this is from the
leaders of Life Sciences today so think
about it think how much opportunity
there is in front of you 90 percent of
what there is to discover is still ahead
of us
now I turn to the investment bankers and
I said well I don't understand this now
you are investing good dollars on people
who just admitted in front of you that
they know less than 10% and what they
need to know can you imagine and the
reason is simple it is such a great
challenge and the risk reward is so
great if you can find just a cure for
one of the major diseases of mankind you
will affect that relationship between
our environment and ourselves so it's
important I think to keep that in
perspective and to understand that there
is a real race going on between our
ability to understand how we respond to
our environment biologically and our
ability to change that environment in
ways and consequences that we with
consequences that we may not always
predict so as the NIH director I have to
give you some advice about how to
conduct yourself then for the next
challenge if that's the challenge that
we think is there and now I can only do
this with no certainty obviously about
what the right answer is I can only talk
to you about myself and the rules I've
used in life to go around and do this
first and foremost I learned one thing
because I came from another country
actually I came from Algeria when I was
24 years old to a
and emigrated and I had $300 in my
pocket new wife and no no friends no
family and basically this is where I
learned that you can't make a
contribution
unless you're connected to others and
you're able to connect to others so I
develop these roles called my 5050 roles
you have to have a balance in life
because you never know when you're going
to need the interactions of others so
what are these 5050 roles well the first
role that I'd like to share with you is
this today you're going to receive a
diploma what you know today I can assure
you is 50 percent wrong and 50 percent
right the challenge for you now is to
figure out what part is right and what
part is wrong now don't take my speech
as an excuse to go and ask for a
reimbursement on your tuition that's and
I don't think they will do that but on
the other hand I think it's a very
important way to look at the knowledge
fund that you have as new scientists new
graduates of MIT I think it is important
to also realize that in life many of
your contributions will not come from
your core discipline they will come from
disciplines that you probably have no
contact with typically and this is the
other fifty-fifty role that I will like
to leave you with read 50% what you read
in the area that you're interested in
but make sure that 50% of what you read
is unrelated to what you have to do and
I did this consistently because I had to
learn a new language I had to connect
with new friends and new disciplines 50%
of what I read was in radiology I loved
medical imaging because it combined
mathematics and physics which I love in
medicine which I think gave me the human
contact and that's why I worked and made
these contributions but 50% of the time
I would read things outside of radiology
it's really fun to see the world that
way but it's also more fun to understand
that you are
smarter when you're in a company of
smarter people than you it is amazing to
see the enrichment that you get from
interacting with others so my rule is is
that 50% of my friends have to be from
walks of life that are not directly
related to my walk of life and more
importantly I try to make sure that at
least 50% of my friends are smarter than
I am
because you can be assured that at least
half of your life contributions will be
stimulated by others that are
interacting with you and you will
stimulate others as well often you hear
about the spark of genius that somebody
had this unique individual and we all
admire these individuals but it's rarely
true that it happens to people who are
completely isolated throughout
scientific history you've always had
that interaction of people founder
groups that got together and created new
advances witness Watson and Crick Watson
was a zoologist and Crick was a
physicist and coming together the
creative the field of molecular biology
look at laboratories around the world
that have been very productive
they've been productive because they
have in fact encouraged the clustering
of people from diverse backgrounds
coming from diverse horizons with
different ideas now this this process is
admittedly social it is not an
individual process as a process you have
to participate in but now I'm going to
tell you about some of the exceptions
that I've learned as well people will
tell you that if you go and talk about
things you do not understand to people
who do not know you you will tend to
look a little stupid and the objection
that I hear a lot is but you can look
foolish asking questions about fields
you do not understand and and those
people who do not know you well that's
true that's very true I asked a lot of
stupid questions in my life and you will
too but the one thing I can tell you is
that it's not deadly to ask stupid
question what's deadly is to not ask the
right question at the right time the
other is people will also tell you if
you talk too much by your ideas
someone will steal them from you while
my response to that is that if you have
ideas that are so easy to steal from
they must not be that good
in fact my experience is different with
throughly original ideas the response is
that most people don't believe you one
of the three or four things I did in my
life
there were some my original were
fiercely disbelieved and criticized and
initially rejected for both publication
and most importantly NIH funding which
is the agency that I direct today so
don't despair I even carried this
further this 50 50/50 rule further
because I spent half of my life in our
country and half of my life in another
country I don't recommend you push that
to that extent but as any rule that you
make for young colleagues that you talk
to there are big exceptions first this
rule doesn't mean that you should
develop a split personality
it shouldn't split your integrity your
integrity has to be constant a hundred
percent another one is that in affairs
of love I don't think you should play
the 50/50 role that would be deadly so
don't do it
and last but not least I would say you
should have big dreams full dreams
not half dreams you know it's very
simple
you can't put a large box in a small box
well you cannot put a full life in a
small dream box what you need is to have
a box a dream box in a life that is as
full as the potential you have today for
universities and and teachers there's
just no greater satisfaction than seeing
you graduate and enter your professional
calling I think you have the potential
to transform our understanding of the
relationship between humanity and
environm
this century I think you need to do it
and you know something there's nothing
greater than coming from the university
like MIT to be able to do that I
actually read that if you ask yourself
about the 100 governments that existed
in 1900 how many of them 100 governments
that were active in 1900 are still
unchanged today you know what the answer
is - there are only two governments in
the world that stayed stable for the
past 104 years the United States and
Great Britain if you ask yourself the
question what about universities well
let me ask you if you took the Year 1500
and you took the 100 universities that
were active in 1500 how many of them do
you think have survived intact in 2004
the number is 75 out of a hundred so
what I can tell you is that universities
beat governments hence down there is no
institution that can survive as long as
a university if it's cared for by its
graduates and alumni the only
institutions that are longer are the
institutions of the church so I'm sure
that MIT will certainly be here at the
end of the century and many more
centuries to come thanks to you as newly
minted graduate and graduates and future
alumni understand the class of 1954 is
here and I want to salute them for
coming back to their institution this is
you